hello there today we'll look at
topographic vae's learn equivariant
capsules by t anderson keller and max
welling on a high level this paper
proposes a new type of variational auto
encoder where the latent variables
aren't independent but are organized in
a topographic way now what that means
we're going to look at that but in in
essence it means that
it can it can
it can represent
transformations in the real world of a
certain kind
as
transformations inside of the latent
space of the model
so
the whole question is here how do we
build a latent space and a model where
this naturally happens as we train it
so we want the real world to somehow
correspond to the latent space in a way
such that if the real world moves the
latent space moves
equivalently or equivalently that's
where this word is going to come in so
we're going to go through the paper i
have to say i don't
understand this fully as well these
variational frameworks they are always
kind of i feel kind of math heavy and
they take a very different approach than
the papers i might be used to so i'm
going to tell you what i think is going
on here and if i'm completely wrong this
is entirely possible please let me know
all right let's dive in to the paper
this is the first graphic right here
that shows kind of an overview over the
system
so what do they want to achieve what
they
say is we're not going to consider we're
going to try to build a generative model
like a variational autoencoder but we're
not going to consider any kind of data
we're going to consider data essentially
essentially frames of a video so we're
going to assume that what we're looking
at is kind of a video and the transition
in the transitions inside the video are
sort of continuous
sort of monotonic and and and
and
slow so here you can see the
7 rotates slowly and also changes its
color slowly relatively monotonously
over this sequence
so what they're going to say is we're
gonna our model is going to take
um
this entire sequence one a picture is
going to be kind of the focus here so
this green one is the focus but we're
going to take in this entire sequence
right here into the model
and we want the model to come up with a
latent representation of the focus image
in this case it's going to be we'll jump
a step here is going to be this thing
right here let's call that i don't even
remember how they call it let's call it
like z-hat okay this is a latent
representation of the focus image
and now obviously in a regular
variational autoencoder i could now push
this again into the decoder and get back
the same image and and i can do so here
as well
however we want something else as well
we also want that if i now
transform my latent space in a certain
way and this way is going to be this
role operation in this paper if i
transform
my
latent space in this way
i want this to correspond to moving
forward in this sequence right so i have
a sequence as an input and i say well my
latent space should be such that if i
perform certain operations right here in
this case i roll by 10
that that corresponds not to the picture
that i've input but to the picture that
would be
if i were to observe this transition ten
steps into the future
so roll by ten and roll in this case
means you can see here uh they have two
of these what they call you know
capsules i think they call them capsules
the left one and the right one and the
roll simply means that i take every
variable latent variable and i simply
roll them forward so this is over the
latent dimension i just
roll them forward by one step i do that
ten times this is as you can see this is
arranged in sort of a taurus here in a
1d taurus so i can just roll this around
and also this capsule i can just roll it
around 10 times and that hopefully if we
train the model correctly should
correspond to
not the input image but the image that
is 10 steps into the future okay so
that is the goal now we don't want to
train a model explicitly to predict 10
steps into the future that would be it
would be a valid task but it's not what
this model wants what this model wants
is say can we build a model architecture
in the latent space architecture such
that this is kind of happens
automatically and let's see well
um
you can already see kind of how this
latent space comes to be i said this z
hat here is going to be the latent
representation you can see that is not
the thing that is directly output by the
encoder the encoder in this case outputs
many things so it outputs a z variable
so the z hat is what i call kind of z
normalized the z variable is kind of z
unnormalized so it outputs a z variable
for the focus image but it also outputs
this u squared variable or it outputs
the u variables which we then square
so these u variables right here are
output i'm going to guess this is from
this image and this is from this image
and this is from this image and also
kind of look into the future right here
and uh
yeah so i have these u variables and i
define sort of a a window a context
window around which i look
and i also predict them i square them
and then i sum them all up i pull the
square root right here and i divide
so this is why i say kind of a
normalized z is what comes out of this
but it's fairly fairly complicated right
but this is going to
in a way encourage this uh behavior so
let's see why that is
and for that i want to just draw back a
little bit to like a regular vae a
regular variational auto encoder so if
in a regular vae you have like an image
this is encoded
decoded and you get back an image all
right so
in a regular vae
what you assume is you assume that the
latent space is sort of made up out of
these independent latent variables
latent random variables they're gaussian
distributed and yeah there i already
said they're independent from each other
and
you you claim if i know
the
latent variables so essentially if i
know the mean and variance of these then
you know producing an image is is easy
right um
you can simply train a neural network i
input you know which
which var
i input what values my latent variables
are or how the gaussians are
parameterized alternatively i input that
and i train the decoder to produce a
picture from that that is easy the
question is
if i have a picture
trusty cat right here
if i have a picture what
are the corresponding latent variables
you know what what are the values of the
latent variables um that makes sense
right here
and of course in a va we train the
encoder and the decoder jointly such
that they cooperatively can construct
this latent space like okay how how
should how should the latent space look
from which the decoder decodes
but i just want to turn your
attention to the question of the
encoder's job is essentially to take in
an image
and produce
what values the latent variables are
and the latent variables are assumed to
be independent from each other and
gaussian distributed
now this is where this model right here
differs okay so this model says
well we're going to assume we have
observed and latent variables observe
variables x and latent variables t
observed or i guess the images or the
image sequences and t are the latent
variables
so this i guess would this would be
equivalent to z hat what i call z hat
they call t
all right so
they say we'll formulate the joint
distribution note that in this framework
in these variational frameworks i i
don't
it's not my thing either but what you do
is you always you propose a mechanism by
which the data and the by which the
variables are are generated so you
as a designer of the algorithm propose
the structure of how the latent
variables um
work together and then
you have some small parts in there that
you say well these things i don't know
i'm going to let a neural network do
these things but essentially you come
and you impose a structure upon the
world right and you know if you get the
structure correct your model will work
fine if you don't get the structure
correct your model won't work fine but
this is a bit of a different way of
working than you know saying well i
train a convnet
to predict
so
we're going to propose our structure
we're going to say
the joint distribution of observed and
latent variables factorizes into these
two it factorizes into this conditional
so if i have the latent variables right
then what are the images
and times the prior across the latent
variables
now we already seen this distribution
it's the first one is listed here again
this
conditional distribution that's simply
your decoder in the vae framework
and that's written here it essentially
says well to produce an image i'm going
to put t the latent variable into this
neural network g right here
and that will give me the distribution
of my output image so this is your
decoder in the vae
now
the interesting part and where it
differs from a regular vae is right here
where they say well how do our latent
how does our latent space look well this
is zooming around
our latent space isn't a independent
gaussians it's actually this tpot
distribution this topographic uh product
no
where where does it i forgot what it i
forgot what it's what it's called a
topographic product of student t's
uh model the tpot topographic product of
student t
that's going to be our distribution and
that distribution is going to encourage
this topographically organized latent
space
all right so we can ask
how does it how does it do that note
that the encoder isn't here yet because
we've only we've defined we've imposed
the generative process
of the data
the generative process starts at the
latent space i said if i know what the
latent variables are i can just ask my
decoder to produce an image so this
distribution here tells us you know the
latent variables are distributed like
this and then there we go
now obviously
what we want is we want our encoder to
produce the variables the latent
variables but we also want what the
encoder produces to follow this
distribution right here
and that's going to be the sort of
difficulty right here because what we
know what we can train with back
propagation
is
pretty much gaussians so you know like
we can train things where we can apply
the re-parameterization trick
um
that's stuff we can backprop through
stuff we can
gaussians we can sample from efficiently
and so on we have closed form solution
for the
kl divergences in the objectives so
essentially what we can do in these
variational frameworks is gaussians okay
not
topographic product of student t's
however
here they show
okay we can in fact construct a product
of student t's this is no this is not
yet
a topographic product it's just a
product of student t's
um distribution from gaussians and that
is i take one z variable and i take a
bunch of u variables and they're all
distributed like gaussians
and i square the u's
i sum them up
i well i average them and then i take
the square root and i divide z by that
and this variable right here that's
going to be a univariate student t
random variable
this should be kind of known if you've
ever taken statistics or like
use the t-test for anything okay and you
know this is already quite familiar and
i can extend this now to the
multi-dimensional case so if t is a
multi-dimensional student t's random
variable composed of independent z's and
u's then we can construct t as a vector
and that is going to be distributed
according to a product of student t's
variable
and this should connect to what we've
seen before right
we said that this model's organization
of the latent space is pretty much of
this form that we saw right here we have
the z variable divided by the square
root of the sum of the squared u
variables and now we learn how
we can construct the
product of student t's latent space
given
z and u
independent gaussians
and that is you know now it should
connect for you um
in
deep learning variational frameworks we
can work pretty much only with gaussian
random variables in this model we want
to work with
product of student t random variables
and here is the way how we can
construct the product of student t
random variables from gaussian random
variables so that's why
here
we
the neural networks will output the z
and the u
that's what they will output that's
those are those are gaussians or
supposed to be gaussians and then we
transform them by dividing them and
summing them up in this way
um to
the latent variable that the decoder
receives which is this z-hat or t i
guess
to this is what the decoder receives so
we know that if the encoder outputs
gaussian random variables the decoder
will receive a
product of student t random variable
now why is the product of student t
random variable special in any way
because it enables us to what they call
here introduce topography
um in essence and they formulate this a
little bit what it does is it it it lets
if
if some of the u's in this sum and some
of the u in this sum are the same
which you can see by the indices in this
case they are not but if some are shared
that means that the two are the two t
variables not the two z the two t
so this is one t and this is another t
right this is t1
this is t2
lots of t
these two variables will no longer be
independent they will actually be
dependent on each other
so this is a way how we can construct
latent spaces where some of the
variables are actually correlated or in
some other way have have higher order
correlations with each other meaning
that the value of one is not independent
from the value of the other one and that
is pretty much a basis for what we want
for constructing these topographic uh
latent spaces
so here they say introducing topography
essentially what we're going to do is
we're not we're going to define
neighborhoods
across our u variables
and
we're going to share the u variables
according to these neighborhoods
and that's going to make the in the
components of t dependent on each other
and this sounds complicated but
essentially you can imagine instead of
having like four latent random variables
which are all gaussians now we have
simply one set of
z variables and one set of
u variables and we're going to consider
an entire sequence and not just one one
image right so we're going to consider
an entire sequence of images like this
right here
every image produces one z and one u
variable and then when we consider an
image let's say this is the focus right
now we consider it's z
and we consider a neighborhood of use
and that's just going to amount
sort of like a convolution like this is
maybe a neighborhood of three so we're
going to consider this u this u and this
u so we're going to construct the z on
top of the fraction divided by
this thing
squared
this bubble here squared this bubble
here squared square root of top on top
of that and that's going to be
our t so the t for this image right here
that's going to be this whole fraction
so when we train the vae we input the
whole sequence we focus on for example
this picture we construct its t by
looking at its z and its neighborhood of
use then we put that t into the decoder
the decoder is going to produce an image
and then we can apply a loss function
between those two okay
so
that is the loss that's the loss
function right the loss function
note that the loss function doesn't say
um
you need if you roll 10 times then it
needs to be the picture that's 10 times
ahead
that is not the case at all we actually
don't have the role function in here
but even now even once we introduce the
role function in the uh in the latent
space we're not going to explicitly
train the model to predict the future
we're simply going to construct as we
did here the latent space um such that
it uh
such that this naturally happens so how
are we going to do this
almost the same and here yeah they talk
about capsules
so you can see that
they divide this neighborhood
structures of the w defines the
neighborhood structure you can see here
some of the u's they are connected and
then other ones are connected but these
u's are not connected with those
uh
they kind of talk about capsules
essentially it's just that they make
some of the variables dependent on each
other and some not
uh or
or
when they do these neighborhood things
they just have two sets of variables
like they have two sets of z's and u's
and they only
yeah they construct two t variables and
that that's what they call capsules that
i don't i don't know why the capsule
terminology enters this paper
necessarily um but
you know they
they want to draw a connection here
so
temporal coherence now we get to how do
we organize this latent space such that
the role operation now also gets in and
this is pretty simple it's actually just
an extension of this right here so here
if you consider these images here as
images of a sequence we always said well
you need to be connected to sort of your
your neighboring variables
and now
sorry your neighboring uh
u variables as they are right and now
we're going to say the same thing but
but
i'm going to draw
the critical path here again so this
we have a z variable right here we have
u variables from the neighborhood okay
and
we're going to take the z variable on
top of the fraction
and we're going to take the u variables
below the fraction right here
like so like so like so now
before
we do this
before we take the u variables here
below the fraction we're going to roll
the u variables according to their
distance from
according to their distance from
the focus so in this case this would be
simply one roll back this would be
simply one roll forward
so
in the language of this paper what this
means is that we don't want
um
we
we don't want this image
or
given a particular position in this
image right this position right here
if we simply apply the classic
neighborhood structure we say
we want this position in this image to
be correlated with the same position
um
a step back and a step forward
now
if we construct the role like this
what we're saying is no no no i don't
want i want
i want this position to be correlated
with
maybe this position here and this
position there like slightly behind and
slightly ahead
but i'm obviously not going to tell the
model what i expect i simply say
please
this image is one time stack
this image is one time step back from me
please roll the latent space by one
and that's going to be
your relevant variable and in this case
it's please roll the latent space of
this thing one forward and that's going
to be your relevant latent
variable so
it's not that we train
we we train rolling
this t variable here because the t is
what finally
um comes out we're not training this t
to roll forward or back
and then predict 10 steps ahead we're
simply saying
how you are influenced you as a focus
how you are influenced by pictures
before and after you
you're not simply taking into account
their latent variables you're going to
take into account rolled versions of
their latent variables
in order for you to reconstruct yourself
in the training objective
and it turns out at least that's how i
understand it right and it turns out so
here you can see the the whole process
we're going to take images i'm going to
produce mean and variance of late of
gaussian variables for the z and the u
variables
so if you had just the vae it would just
be this right here and those would be
your latent variables but not here we
produce two sets z's and use
then we're going to construct the t
variables i don't know why this is on
the bottom here but then we're going to
construct the t variables according to
this formula
w here is the neighborhood structure you
define it u and z are the variables you
produced from your encoder or you
sampled from what your encoder produced
and mu here is also a learnable
parameter a learnable mean parameter
and then you stick this these t's
into
you're going to stick these these into
this neural network now here it says z
and zl and ul but essentially this here
this here
these create t
oh here it's here you're going to stick
the t into your decoder neural network
remember the the g the how do we get
the picture from the latent variable
that's the decoder i'm going to stick
that into the decoder and out you get an
image and you train it
with the classic elbow the evidence
lower bound which says okay
what i want is
i want to reconstruct the picture
accurately right that's this term right
here to reconstruct the picture
accurately but i also want that my
z
well essentially what i want is that my
t
variables are distributed according to
this
tpot distribution i want to enforce that
but i can't right i can work with
gaussians so but what i can do is i can
say well the z variables and the u
variables they must be as gaussian as
possible so i penalize the kl divergence
between
what i produce which is this right here
and the gaussian like a a pure gaussian
this has a closed form i can cur i can
calculate kl divergences from what i
produce with gaussians no problem
okay and that's the training loss and i
simply average that over the input
sequence
and
you know there there you go
now
the evaluation of these things i have to
say after reading through the
experiments in the evaluations this is
this is a
paper kind of an idea at least i feel so
right correct me if i'm wrong but i feel
that this is sort of an idea paper it's
like here's an idea it works if we you
know specifically construct a data set
for it and if we specifically also the
experiments are appear to be kind of
fiddly like you have to
really you know get your parameters
right to make this work but if you do
then you know the model behaves as you
as you expect and so they measure things
like
is the rolled version of the latent
variables really equal to the latent
variables a couple of times steps ahead
and
things like this
and they they produce these these maps
so here is one where the latent space
isn't a 1d taurus like we looked at so
1d taurus is this right so you go around
around around sorry
this is a 2d taurus so a 2d torus is
like a plane and if you leave here you
come back here and if you leave here you
come back here so if you if you roll
this up
and then you you have a pipe and if you
close the pipe you have like a doughnut
so that's a taurus
so if they have a topographic space like
a taurus they and they simply apply that
to mnist the test set sort of looks like
this
i don't know if you want to read
something into this like
feel free
i'm not sure
but in when they go with the sequences
so here you see like the sequences i
think on top is what they input and then
this is the continuation that the model
doesn't see on the bottom is what the
model produces you can see the model
does
get to a point where it understands how
these sequences
go
here right it goes larger larger and
then it kind of
flips around to the smallest this is a
expected behavior
here as well the rotation it model
continues the rotation and it turns out
even if the model is just trained with
um they have these these experiments
single transformations so either a role
sorry either a rotation or a scale
transformation or a color change
it
can generalize to
multiple transformations at once as you
can see right here colors and rotations
can the model can
generalize to that
fairly fairly well
okay i don't want to get too much into
the experiments because i'm not sure how
important that the numbers here are i'm
safe to say if you construct this model
and if you apply to the you know
problems where exactly this is needed
and if you get the hyper parameters
right
then this model actually works it's
better whereas a regular neural network
it it could not
easily incorporate the concept of these
slow changing transitions it would sort
of have to learn okay what color comes
after red orange okay what color comes
after orange yellow okay what color
comes after yellow green
i guess the other model has to learn
that as well but
this model it cannot represent the
transition in a sequence as sort of as
it has to learn it
as a parameterized function
rather than being able to map it to an
internal transformation of the rate of
the latent space like the topographic
vae can do
okay that was it for me i'm not
competent enough to tell you how big of
a step this is it feels to me like
a little step
it might be a giant step i don't know
okay um it feels to me like it's kind of
an idea paper to show something neat
that you could do in an idealized case
it might be that this is a
much bigger deal than i think i thought
it was a cool paper i thought it was a
neat idea it's written even though it's
i think kind of you know
more high level i'm sorry more more
so
i'm not as competent at it but i could
still make sense of it so if you enjoy
this give it a read uh yeah let me know
if you have any comments and that was it
bye bye thanks